[Music]
oh
now you might think this is a bit of an
excessive reaction
but as you can see we're already having
a pretty cramp ass day
sweet lord jesus brought me to the city
of angels
for a purpose yeah
they do grow pretty in texas
you can always work for me you know
working at the club aka selling a bunch
of drugs to la's horniest
crackheads
i should have listened to you all the
money and all his [ __ ] drugs are gone
okay
find a way to get me that 20 grand back
[ __ ]
[Music]
i know your plates i know your friends
this is a scary drug dealer
so i'm trying to make a good impression
with now i need your help more than ever
show me that life
you're a [ __ ] badass
[Music]
who are you supposed to tell people we
came to hollywood to start a convent
i haven't seen you before well look at
god just working his ways
do you know where to get waxed around
here
always did have flavor for danger
i hate them should i
kill them
[Music]
[Applause]
so what do i know about you
[Music]
you